je suis pour la vérité peu importe qui
la raconte
je suis pour la justice peu importe en
faveur de qui elle tourne lui
18 ans 10 mois et 24 jours c'est le
temps que voir nguema passés en prison
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour le meurtre de
chuck permane
j'ai contribué à sceller le destin de
warren avec une série d'articles
a t'on jeté un homme innocent en prison
elle jouer un rôle pour le faire accuser
oh
[Musique]
à
ouais
tu m'as départ comme un psychopathe pour
y était maintenant ville dans un
bâtiment en cui tome qui me connaissent
bien
j'ai senti votre mensonge avant même que
vous ayez commencé à l'ouvrir
comme une mère et ses deux filles
pouvait-elle temps pendant que se jouait
un drame aussi et on n'a jamais retrouvé
larmes du clan caisses du cash
laisse tomber je vais vraiment te
pourrir la vie ici
y'a monstres cachés en chacun de nous tu
plais trop peur
et le vôtre vous avez quoi l intérieur
joue avec la vie de certaines personnes
est ce que tu es prête à faire face aux
conséquences tu crois que la justice à
verser un jour tous les secrets titah
poppy parnell de me lâcher vous avez
emmerder sa famille
aucune idée de ce que j'ai fait pour
cette famille dans une famille reçoit
déjà des zones
je dois savoir la vérité sur ce qui
s'est passé
ils vont la voir leur spectacle
[Musique]